36 ist jetzt echt ich zurzeit nicht mal
der dom kann mich um die uhrzeit auf
montag wird eigentlich zusammen mit
shell die nach stuttgart fahren damit er
mir ein bisschen mehr der kamera hilft
ja stellt jetzt verschlafen
ich bin übrigens hier in stuttgart teil
wegen dessen spielzeuge der welt haben
auf jeden fall machen wenn er richtig
leistungsfußball challenge bei mir
findet ihr so ein bisschen wie halten es
aber die richtige fussball challenge
findet auf dem kanal der friedlinger
statt es geht auf jeden fall um die
neuen nerven blaster die somit ca die
krassesten glas das sind dies gibt keine
freien felder da hinten könnte jeder
irgendein trick machen
das ist auf jeden fall die jungs vom
kanal kritikers und wir machen jetzt
gleich eine challenge die besteht mich
einerseits aus diesen nerv blaster und
ich denke also die ganze zeit ich hätte
am liebsten diesem jörg glaser auch als
kind gehabt
wir haben nur somit so holz wurden
rumgespielt auf jeden fall machen wie
jetzt die challenge also nerv blaster
zusammen mit fußball
während die kritiker jüngst an den
parcours durch die gegangen sind habe
ich neben anm eine brezel gegessen und
als die jungs zum ersten mal trainiert
haben habe ich so langsam angefangen
nicht auf zu werben
in baden trainieren ich bin eine wahl
von denen fast thema mein rat ist
können wir die im schnitt größer machen
nachdem ich dann noch ein bisschen
schwachsinn gemacht habe ging es auch in
die silos mit meinem ersten richtigen
durchgang der challenge also epische
musik an und will ab
ok
der kanzler ist der einstige grenzen
durch glück denn ich bin noch ohne mathe
hat er uns geschlagen kommt noch das
kann auch noch so voll dass gegen den
fußballer snacks zwischendurch
wahrscheinlich tripolis
[Musik]
wenn wir einen durchgang besonnen wurde
machen will sagt jetzt haben meine
lieben freunde ich habe mir diese pinkl
schnelle sondern darauf gesetzt bin los
gespendet und nach ultrasone habe so wie
man das von ihr mann skills kennt
natürlich überhaupt keine von den
dächern getroffen dann allerdings
manfred habe in den winkel das in der
tat ich wolle dagegen mit der
sonnenbrille ab zum 16 und warten
natürlich auch einige auf dann 1 gegen
den europaliga und dann ging's bergab
habt ihr den ultras laster verloren
dann der aufreger kein getroffen und
ausgesprochen hat auch keine kraft mehr
und das ist auch vorbei dann sollten
sich einfach mal alle hinsetzen die
keine schießen bekommen
spannung auch letzten acht ansonsten
könnten die beschreibung guck mal findet
ihr deren instagram verlinkt meine
instagram und ihr könnt auch noch ein
paar pflaster gewinnen
also sollte auch vorbei und ich keinen
kommentar